[Musique]
le
où
[Musique]
mais
on a voulu mettre en oeuvre des moyens
faut savoir quasiment doubler notre
capacité mécanique que
traitement doublé
nos équipes en place afin d'assurer tout
le traitement et puis aussi travailler 7
jours sur 7 24 heures sur 24
[Musique]
oh
non
moi je
oui
au monde
[Musique]
participarc manougian de l'hypothermie
tine faty et parcs éoliens dont les
causes il a été vérifié au tt non si
saad haddad verts eelv à nantes les
répartissent couramment et dit les pré
conditionné par contre possible et les
truies reprendraient si le dire n'est
pas causé des pertes importantes et
notre titre accor perd 90 tiers disent
choqués et là que zuhra nancy à la
mesure annoncée à correct à windy la
moindre inattention n'accusera corée
[Musique]
à
en machin là si vous marchez tout l'art
il a franchement vous allez voir un ou
deux matchs au sol et il ya des
individus qui prend ses immenses et
porter directement et ça c'est pas
évident vraiment le gouvernement doit
trouver des moyens et de stratégie pour
remédier à cela
[Musique]
non
une fois le masque enlevé il doit être
introduite dans un sac poubelle
bon pour ceux qui sont à la maison comme
on c'est toute la population qui étudie
les masques vous l'enlevez vous devez
avoir un plastique dans lesquels vous
introduisez le masque qui doit être
après attaché voulu jeter dans la
poubelle on ne le met pas à la portée
des enfants
[Musique]